so Steve Bannon has a new nickname
sloppy Steve deemed to be that by
President Trump will talk about that we
will also talk about the Trump
administration's new Marijuana Policy
it's got a lot of people up in arms or
at least they would be up in arms if
they could get up off their couch and
leave the Doritos behind I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show
so today is mailbag day so if you're
going to subscribe you should do it
right now so you can get your questions
into the mailbag now not later right now
so go over and subscribe to the website
right now and be involved that way also
we are going to get to all of the
late-breaking news the FBI has now
launched another investigation against
Hillary Clinton's foundation which is
just incredible and we'll talk about the
ramifications of that just a lot to get
you today but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at wink so
let's be real about this you know you
need a drink at dinner these days you
just do okay because let's look at that
news cycle and you know you do and
that's what wink is therefore what wink
is really there for is for people don't
know anything about wine so you're
somebody like me and you spent your
entire childhood drinking you know cheap
kosher wines and you don't know anything
about wine generally and now you are an
adult and you're going over to
somebody's house and you need to bring
over a fine bottle of wine but you don't
know the difference between Manischewitz
and something good and so instead you
need to go over to wink calm you go over
to link calm winc and winks wine experts
at select wines match to your taste
personalized for you shipped right to
your door it starts with just $13 a
bottle that makes great gift this
holiday season and you can send a
personalized gift card and let your
recipients choose their own wine they
have a palette quiz of how a profile
quiz in which what kind of foods do you
like what kind of foods you like to pair
and then they recommend a wine just for
you discover great wine today go to try
winked calm / bend get $20 off your
first shipment that's tri wink winc calm
/ Ben and get 20 bucks off your first
shipment each month there are new
delicious wines the one that is
apparently very popular right now is
called the summer water rose egg there
are no membership fees you can skip any
month you can cancel anytime and
shipping is complimentary and if you
don't like the bottle they sent you then
you can send it but then they will
replace it with another bottle no
questions asked so go to try wink t ry
winc comm / Ben and get $20 off your
first shipment again try winked comm /
Ben use the / Ben's they know that we
sent you alright so we begin today with
this supposedly bombshell book from
Michael Wolfe so there's been a lot of
hubbub over the Trump administration's
treatment of the Michael Wolfe book so
Michael Wolfe go recall is this
journalist who's kind of sketchy I
remember during the Bush administration
there was a journalist named Kitty Kelly
and Kitty Kelly came out with a couple
of
that were very gossipy about what had
happened that one was about the Bush
administration and others about the JFK
administration and it was all very
gossipy it was very hard to pack down
what was true and what was false and it
sounds a lot like Michael Wolf's book is
the same way basically he was given
large-scale access to the West Wing
apparently by Steve Bannon who allowed
him in and just let him sit on the couch
outside the West Wing and as Wolfe says
the West Wing is very small it is I've
been there it's a pretty small area and
the and they're constantly people of
note walking by and so wolf would you
sit there and then he would sort of
buttonhole people and ask them questions
and then he writes this book and this
book is filled with kind of juicy
anecdotes stuff about how Trump would
make his own sheets he didn't trust
other people to do his sheets and how he
would eat KFC because he was afraid of
being poisoned and how he would watch TV
endlessly and fulminate about his aides
and how he would just go crazy on a
routine basis how everybody around Trump
thought that he was a and a crazy
person and how they would tell the
public that he was a genius and then
secretly they would tell Michael Wolfe
that he was adult and all of this kind
of stuff
so what to believe in what not somebody
first of all don't believe everything
that you read in Michael Wolf's book as
I said earlier I think that it should
have been subtitled as told by Steve
Bannon because it's pretty clear that
Bannon is the guy who was spilling his
guts to Michael Wolfe it was Ben and who
just got blown up for spilling his guts
to Michael Wolfe suggesting that all of
his enemies in the White House were
guilty of criminal conduct during the
campaign that's what has led President
Trump to go all-out against Steve Ben
and now so he released his statement
about Bandhan nuking him two days ago
yesterday he came out and had the White
House attack Bannon said that Breitbart
should probably fire him sarah huckabee
sanders was asked specifically whether
Breitbart should consider a consider
firing ban and here's what she had to
say we were eager to call on ESPN to
fire one of his sports casters for crew
size
President Trump and it wasn't just
criticizing it different it should
Breitbart part ways with Steve Batman
after your comments in these books I
certainly think that it's something they
should look at and consider Brian thanks
he said a couple things here number one
of course the Trump administration feels
this way second is it appropriate for
the Trump administration to be dictating
to an private news organization what
exactly they should be doing with their
own staffing the answer is no I opposed
it when they when they told ESPN they
should fire Janelle Hill or suspend
rimmel Hill I feel the same way about
ban and even though I think Bannon is is
a turd of a human being I don't think
that the White House should be telling
private organizations how to run their
business on the other hand since
Breitbart is basically the press adjunct
to the white house I guess that they can
fire people who are in-house so I
suppose the day they have a case to be
made that they can fire Steve Ben and
from the White House considering that it
was basically just the press outlet for
the Trump campaign during the campaign
itself Bannon has not only lost the
support of the White House he has also
lost the support of the Mercer's first
of course he lost the support of
President Trump so very late last night
President Trump slapped out at sloppy
Steve over allegations in the book he
said quote I authorized zero access to
White House actually turned him down
many times for author of phony book I
never spoke to him for book full of lies
misrepresentations and sources that
don't exist look at this guy's past and
watch what happens to him and sloppy
Steve okay first of all great nickname
again second slow clap in two days for
President Trump this is an excellent
nickname this one goes up in the in the
treasured Halcyon and the treasured wing
of the Hall of Fame of Trump nicknames
Raymond there's a little Marco and
there's low-energy Jeb and sloppy Steve
is really high up there I mean that's
that's that'll stick that'll stick
because Steve is a sloppy guy in a
variety of ways so that is good stuff
from Trump Trump came out today and he
said that the Mercer's made a good move
by getting rid of sloppy Steve so he's
just gonna keep banging on this drum
Bannon for his part is trying to kowtow
before Trump which makes sense since the
Mercer's came out and slammed ban and
the Mercer's if you don't know are a
very the number one funding family for
the for the Republican Party essentially
and they were the number one funders of
President Trump during his general
election cycle Rebecca Mercer is the is
the woman who is largely responsible for
deciding where the Mercer family money
goes and she said I support President
Trump and the platform upon which
selected my family and I have not
communicated with Steve Danon many
months that have provided no financial
support to his political agenda nor do
we support his recent actions and
statements that's a pretty rare
statement from Rebecca who apparently
tends to be rather reclusive in in
public her father had disassociated from
Breitbart and from Bannon back in early
November so they've been basically
cutting off ties for weeks now with
Bannon there's a report that they've
even cut off the funding for bandhans
private security team so he's basically
been isolated at this point has Bannon
and that of course has led him to one
conclusion he must hang on at Breitbart
right it's the only thing that matters
to Bannon right now he has to hang on at
Breitbart if he loses his perch at
Breitbart he's done as a human he no
longer has the ability to get in good
with Trump right the idea I think for
Bannon is if I hang on long enough if I
just hang out here long enough then at
some point Trump will bring me back in
the fold but Corey Lewandowski or Sam
Nunn Berg or a bunch of other people I'm
not sure that's the case I think that
once you've burned your bridges with the
with the president's children like all
of them then you're going to eventually
reach the point where there is no way
for you to avoid being blown out
basically I think that maybe or abandon
is but Bannon feels like if I just stick
around a Breitbart long enough and then
something bad happens to Jared and
Ivanka legally then I'll rush back in
and Trump still has my phone number if
he's no longer a Breitbart that's no
longer an option so he's trying to hang
on with the skin of his teeth
Larry soul of who is Andrew Breitbart
old business partner and best friend
Larry refuses to get rid of Bannon is is
my impression from the outside I don't
have any inside information on that but
if I had to guess that would make a lot
of sense it was Larry who brought in
Bannon in the first place out of I think
personal weakness but in any case I'm
the idea that he's gonna dump man and by
the side of the road is unlikely I think
the Mercer's would have to force the
issue
so Bannon is trying to hang on the way
he's hanging on is basically by kowtow
into Trump and then hoping that Trump
bats off of him so here was Ben and
yesterday after all these quotes come up
about how Bannon thinks that Trump is a
crazy person and is going to either be
impeached or resign and how his children
are all criminals now he comes out he
says no no no Trump's wonderful Trump's
great so he hears Bannon on Sirius XM
radio I know because I know at least one
person who listened to it which was
apparently their entire audience so here
here we go President I States is a great
man you know I support him day in and
day out whether going through the
country given the Trump miracle speech
or on the show on the website so I don't
think you have to worry about that but I
appreciate
the kind words okay so the idea that he
has been supporting Trump day in and day
out is sort of bolide by the fact that
he let this reporter into the White
House who then proceeded to savage the
White House from every conceivable angle
so this brings us to the actual nature
of the book the actual nature of the
book it has a lot of problems the book
is fire and fury again it is a it is a
deeply gossip ridden account and there
are a lot of problems with the book
itself it has all of these sort of weird
anecdotes and you don't know where their
source - because wolf doesn't have any
endnotes is my impression he doesn't say
this is from my conversation with Steve
Bannon in in the West Wing or this is
from my conversation with Jared Kushner
or this is from a conversation with Mike
Pence it doesn't have any of those
footnotes there's no way to tell what is
true and what is not in these accounts
but we know already and there are some
things in this book that are just not
true right we know there are accounts
that are simply false there are certain
descriptions of people that are just not
true and in just a second I'm going to
tell you about some of the instances in
the book that are clearly untrue I mean
I can personally attest to them being
untrue in just one second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at ring so rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer we have ring.com at
our house we have the the device on our
front gate today over a million people
use the amazing ring video doorbell that
ring video doorbell basically the way it
works somebody rings the doorbell and
instead of you having to be home in
order to answer you can pick it up from
your phone anywhere in the country right
you can just pick up your phone makes it
look like you're right at home and that
way nobody's gonna be robbing your house
because they think that your home that's
what the bringing video doorbell is for
you can screen people who you don't want
to come over so you really don't like
your in-laws they ring the doorbell and
you can pick up and you can say sorry
I'm not home go away right and do
whatever you want ring knows home
security begins at the front door but it
doesn't end there so now they're
extending that same level of security to
the rest of your home with the ring
floodlight Kim the floodlight camera is
a motion-activated camera and floodlight
that connects right to your phone with
HD video and two-way audio that lets you
know the moment anyone steps on your
property again you can even set off an
alarm directly from your phone so your
property will always be safe ring
floodlight offers the ultimate in home
security high visibility flood lights a
powerful HD camera that puts security in
your hands save up to one hundred and
fifty bucks off that ring of security
kit when you go to ring calm / Ben
that's ring calm / Bennigan's ring calm
/ Ben you get a hundred and fifty
dollars off that ring of security kit it
is vital it is necessary to protect your
family ring.com
slash venues that slash pens they know
that we sent you so here's what we know
in the book that is not true in the
michael wolf book fire and fury which is
soaring on the bestseller charts here's
about how we know their stuff that's not
true so number one it says in the book
that donald trump didn't know who john
bainer was or the Speaker of the House
that in conversations Trump had no clue
who Boehner was when he was recommended
as it possible is a possible chief of
staff that's ridiculous I mean Trump has
golfed with John Boehner John Boehner
was the Speaker of the House for the
first four months of Trump's
presidential run basically the idea that
that Trump that Trump has no idea who
Boehner is is is really hard to to hold
to scrutiny beyond that it's also
ridiculous to suggest as the book does
that Stephen Miller who is one of trumps
top aides one of his speech writers
can't put together a sentence I mean the
guy did go to I believe Duke Law School
if I'm not mistaken no Stephen did as
well is not only that Stephen was also a
Stephen is a policy wonk so there's an
accusation that Stephen Miller is not in
fact a policy wonk when it comes to
immigration I've spent hours talking
with him about immigration the idea that
he is not a policy wonk is just asinine
Miller didn't go to Zoopla rather he
went to Duke itself so he's a smart
enough guy to go to Duke which is a top
college the idea that he can't write a
sentence is silly
there are other claims in this book that
are being called into question there's a
claim that Sean Hannity
expressed his willingness to let Trump
review questions in advance
Hannity said that he never did that I
don't know whether to believe that or
not the interviews were friendly enough
I don't think Shawn would have to do
that right I mean Shawn could basically
just hit a Trump listen I'm not gonna
sandbag you and Trump would agree
because Shawn would never stand back
Trump so I'm not sure we'd have to
actually offer to supply the questions
another one of trumps top advisers and
Friends Thomas Barrett said or the
president he's not only crazy he's
stupid but Barrett denies have her ever
having made the comment the British
publication claimed that the wolf book
says that Tony Blair former British
prime minister warned Jared Kushner
during the campaign that British spies
could have the campaign under
surveillance but Blair calls that report
a complete fabrication so here's what it
sounds like Michael wolf did when he put
together this book it sounds like
Michael wolf basically sat in the hall
and listen to Steve ban and tell tall
tales around the campfire while roasting
marshmallows and eating s'mores and then
when they were done he just wrote down
everything Steve ban and said and then
he said you filter it out you the reader
it's your job to try and determine
what's true and what's false so you get
a sort of ambiance of what
like in the white house with all the
chaos and all the craziness but it's not
necessarily true that every individual
story is true if that's the case then
there's not much to the book and the
truth is I'm not sure there's much to
the book anyway just because I believe a
lot of the tenem general tenor and tone
issues that the book raises I believe
that Donald Trump is not Phi Beta Kappa
when it comes to policy I don't think
the Donald Trump is is necessarily the
most stable personality I mean but I
thought all of that for the last two
years I mean I've been saying that for
years at this point I'm not sure how you
look at his Twitter account and figure
that this guy is is a is a Washington is
a Washingtonian character it's like
George Washington in his Stalinist in
stalwart US like I just don't I don't
see how you would possibly come away
with that by watching Donald Trump for
any lengthy period of time so what does
the book add the answer is the book
really doesn't add much at all except
for a bunch of accusations by Steve Ben
and that the media want to take
seriously for purposes of trying to
destroy Trump which of course is why
Trump is going directly it Steve Bannon
and directly and why Donald Trump should
go directly it Steve Bennett right
abandon is the guy who wanted to turn
this into a self aggrandizing homage to
him and it was a direct fail and I think
that that makes you know I think makes
perfect sense that Trump decides that he
asked to strike back now the way that
Trump strikes back had ban in which I
think is correct is very different from
the way that Trump strikes back at the
book Trump is now participating in what
we in the internet world called the
Streisand effect so a few years back
Barbra Streisand the legendary singer
and crazed liberal she was she has a
house on the beach down in Malibu and
there was an environmentalist
photographer who had taken some aerial
photos of the beach and it included her
house now you never would have known
that it was her house it didn't label
her house didn't have an arrow that said
Barbra Streisand's house it was just a
picture that included Barbra Streisand's
house and the point of the photos was
not to show where the rich and famous
lived the whole point of the photos was
to show coastal erosion right so the
entire series posed by an
environmentalist guy it wasn't by some
right winger who was trying to stake out
Barbra Streisand's house while she's
selling feelings in the background that
was not the idea here
well what Barbra Streisand did is she
got so mad that she sued the
photographer for something like five
million dollars there's something crazy
she sued the photographer for an
enormous amount of money claiming that
he had violated her privacy rights while
in launching the lawsuit she then made
clear where was she lived so suddenly
the photo which had been been viewed
I think a grand total of like seven
times ever by anyone was viewed by 1.5
million people people flooded onto the
internet to see the pictures of Barbra
Streisand's house and what she would be
so touchy about that she'd sue some
Rando for millions of dollars for
exposing the photo
well bana Trump basically did the same
thing with this book so the book was
gonna get coverage but Trump could have
said all the same things I just said
right Trump could have said listen Steve
Allen's a piece of garbage and falsifies
a lot of stuff this book is driven by
Steve banners agenda but the book is
full of falsehoods and we're not gonna
talk about it anymore right we're just
gonna leave it at that the books full of
falsehoods we're done it's full of a
bunch of crazy stories Steve Bannon has
an agenda he's self driven he's garbage
and everybody would have cheered and
that would been the end of it because by
the way Steve Bannon is garbage if I
haven't made that clear already for the
last few days so or for the last two
years for that matter with that said and
that's not what the Trump administration
decided to do so Trump unleashed his
lawyers on the publisher always a bad
move he sends a letter to the publisher
saying you are going to pull this book
or I am willing to see you for
defamation no okay so as I'm putting on
my lawyer hat defamation against the
President of the United States is not a
thing
okay winning a defamation suit as the
President of the United States is not
going to happen you are a public figure
you're the ultimate public figure and
even and I'm not sure he could prove
anything that was maliciously and
willfully false which is the actual
statement you have to prove malicious
maliciousness right like willful and
malicious and his stefan defamation for
a public figure that's the standard they
willfully knew something was false and
you maliciously published it anyway that
is not going to happen for the President
of the United States particularly since
most people are going to believe a lot
of the allegations that are in the book
anyway including I would I'm sure
members of the jury so that was stupid
by doing that he basically handed a win
to the author of the book again this is
the problem with with trumps major a
tendency to go after anybody who slaps
him is that it puts him in weird
positions where he's actually elevating
the people who are slapping him now I
think he could slap down Bandhan pretty
safely because Bannon used to work for
him Bandon was the barnacle on his butt
so anytime Trump wanted to slap him he
could write Trump could just destroy him
with a single swipe and that's
essentially what Trump has done it's a
different thing when you're talking
about a media member and it isn't great
policy to have the president of the
united states suing individual member
of the media for the stuff that they
write it's just not if Obama had tried
to do this about Edie Klein for example
the entire write would have gone nuts
and I think rightly says so yeah I think
that's bad policy by Trump I think that
it's it's over the top go after Steve
Bam and by all means since he's the one
who's actually the leak he's the guy
who's actually telling all of these tall
tales out of school but going after the
author who you allowed to sit around in
the White House for day after day after
day apparently for months that seems
like a big mistake to me and again it
creates a Streisand effect where
suddenly like last night in DC there
were people who are waiting outside
bookstores at 12:15 at night for the
early release of the book so the book
was actually pushed up for days and the
publisher released the book four days
early specifically so that they could
gain all of the all of the sales from
all of the attention so that's something
that from ought not to have done you
know issuing a cease and desist to
Bannon with with a violation of the NDA
then non-disclosure agreement as I said
yesterday that there's actually a legal
case for that there's no defamation
legal case for President Trump against
Henry Holt and publishers against
Michael Wolfe this particular author
even though the author I think is making
things up even though and or at least
repeating tales that he has not bothered
to verify Woolf by the way says this
openly that this is not his style but he
doesn't actually he doesn't actually
verify the anecdotes that he's told he
just sort of spills it out on the page
and just assumes that everything is true
so that is not called journalism that's
just you being a tape recorder and
that's essentially what Michael Wolfe
did so is this gonna do lasting damage
to the Trump administration that a lot
of people say oh it's a bombshell inside
the Trump administration just a
bombshell is it though is it really do
you really think that members of the
Trump administration are gonna use their
power members of the Trump cabinet or
gonna use their power under the 25th
amendment to suspend Trump from service
for 60 days and then kick it to Congress
where Trump will actually be impeached
which is the actual process under the
25th amendment do you really think
that's what's gonna happen here because
it ain't gonna happen
okay nobody in the West Wing is going to
launch an impeachment move against Trump
on the basis of he's crazy people knew
who Trump was when they voted for him
and people refused to believe anything
that they don't want to believe I was
talking with Andrew Klavan and with
Michael Knowles yesterday or rather I
was not my business partner Jeremy was
and both Clavin and Knowles were
insisting that this is all 40 mega mega
mega chests and I'm just telling you
it's not but if you want to believe that
it is you're going to
that it is so people are still believing
about Trump what it is they want to
believe about Trump and that being the
case none of these new anecdotes are
gonna change one single mind not one
single person in the United States who
didn't think Trump was already crazy is
going to change their mind and not a
single person who thought that Trump is
brilliant is gonna change their mind
based on Michael Wolf's book so the idea
that is a bombshell that really ruins
the administration you Kevin Williams it
had a good line about this right you
can't take down Trump with this kind of
stuff for the same reason that you can
no longer assassinate Abraham Lincoln
right Ambra hem Lincoln's already dead
right Donald Trump cannot be taken down
by this stuff because people who
perceive him to be crazy already
perceived him to be crazy people who
perceive him to be saying already
perceived him to be saying he is what he
is in my view right I don't think that
he's the world's most stable guy I don't
think that he has the character of a
president that I would prefer but I will
enjoy all of the policy wins that he's
brought and I can live with that
cognitive dissonance everybody else
should learn to to and that's just the
way that it works okay so I'm going to
move on to Trump and pot in just a
second I know that's not my
recommendation that we all smoke weed to
get through the next three years of this
or the next seven years of the case
maybe but before I get to that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at blinds calm so you're looking
around your house and you know it looks
shabby but you don't know why well I'm
gonna tell you why it's not just that
you're in the house right it's also that
there are blinds on the windows that
look like they look like crap right
those blinds have been there since
before you bought the house those blinds
been there since 1932 and they are made
of wire frame hangers right they are
just terrible well you're going to
replace them now you're going to listen
to me and you're gonna go over to
blinds.com
they make it really easy for you if
you're not sure what you want or even
where to start go to blinds.com you get
a free online design consultation send
them pictures of your house they send
back custom recommendations from a
professional from what will work with
your color scheme furniture specific
rooms they'll even send you free samples
to make sure everything looks as good in
person as it does online and every order
gets free shipping and this is the best
part if you miss measure you screw up
it's your fault
well then blinds.com will redo it for
you for free they've made it really easy
for you so there's no excuse for your
apartment to look like something out of
the florida project go to the again 20%
off everything at blinds.com when you
use promo code Ben that's blinds.com
promo code Ben get 20% off everything
and that means faux wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more it really
upgrades the look of your house to have
a nice set of of blinds or
like all this just makes your house look
a lot better and you won't look like the
cheapo that you are because even though
you're not spending a lot of money it
looks really good blinds.com promo code
ben and you get 20% off of everything
again use that promo code Ben so that
everybody knows that we sent you okay so
a big policy change or a sort of big
policy change happened yesterday and all
of the pot smokers and threads of pot
smokers are just up in arms at the Trump
administration or as I said earlier they
are too busy staring at their own
fingernails and finding them fascinating
but when the pot wears off and before
they've been able to re-up then they
will be very very exercised about all of
this and then presumably they'll eat a
pizza smell tomorrow weed and go back to
sleep but in any case okay when I make
fun of people who smoke pot folks it's
not because I think pot should actually
be illegal it's because I think you're
stupid if you spend all of your time
smoking pot okay just that I think
you're stupid by the way if you drink
yourself into oblivion too but in any
case here's what actually happened
Attorney General Jeff Sessions on
Thursday rescinded is according to CNN a
trio of memos from the Obama
administration that had adopted a policy
of non-interference with marijuana
friendly state laws there's something
called the Cole rule okay under the Cole
rule it basically said Jim Cole was the
former Deputy Attorney General the whole
idea here was that the Justice
Department was going to let the states
do what they wanted to do it was it was
sort of the equivalent of daca so if you
remember deferred action for childhood
arrivals program was Obama saying I'm
going to use my prosecutorial discretion
to instruct the DOJ not to actually
prosecute cases for the so-called
dreamers that's what daca was the
executive amnesty
well the Cole rule was basically the
same thing for pot distribution so the
move now from Jeff Sessions essentially
shifts federal policy from the hands-off
approach adopted under the previous
administration to unleashing federal
prosecutors across the country to decide
individually how to prioritize resources
to crack down on pop possession
distribution and cultivation of the drug
in states where it is legal so while
many states would decriminalize or
legalize marijuana use here in
California they've decriminalized
marijuana use and the that has obviously
made California just a more wonderful
place to live it was already wonderful
and now just made it a more wonderful
place to live so that everybody on the
streets is smoking pot and the homeless
people who live right outside your house
can now get high in their spare time in
any case the drug is still illegal under
federal law which creates this conflict
federal and state law now let me make my
own position very clear on this I'm in
favor of decriminalization of marijuana
I have been for decriminalization of
marijuana for years I believed the
federal government and the state
government spend far too much time and
effort trying to go after marijuana and
they do a terrible job of it it should
still be heavily regulated for use under
the age of 18 there is serious damage
that is done to teenage brains by repeat
use of marijuana the argument as to
whether marijuana is a gateway drug is
not exactly settled you know people have
said it's not a gateway drug they sell
that's just a myth the data on that are
really mixed when I say they're mixed
what I mean is that the vast majority of
people who use heavier drugs did start
off by using marijuana but it's not
clear whether those people just had a
tendency toward drugs in the first place
and that drove them to use both
marijuana and then have your drugs or
whether they started with marijuana and
they said I'm breaking the law anyway
but I'm not getting high enough so now
I'm gonna try heroin right that's not
it's not clear exactly how that worked
in any case that is it that's an
argument that has not been fully
debunked is the is the gateway drug
issue but as somebody who's in favor of
individual sovereignty and your capacity
to make your own decisions as an adult
including stupid decisions without
government intervention I'm in favor of
marijuana decriminalization I'm I'm more
split when it comes to harder drugs that
are more addictive things like heroin or
things like cocaine there I tend toward
legalization even for those drugs the
truth but when it comes to things like
angel dust or LSD that have actual
externalities where it's gonna cause you
to act in violent ways it actually
changes how you act toward people as
opposed to you just get high and you
stay in your room all day and you and
you drown in your own vomit like that
seems to me that's mostly in a problem
but if you are actually gonna get high
and then go out and kill a child then
yeah and then the drug makes it more
violent it makes you crazy and hyper you
know then then that's a different story
that's my basic take on drug
legalization and decriminalization with
all that said the sessions is now
reversing this Obama era rule so he said
this is a return to the rule of law but
he didn't go as far as some advocates
worried that he would he didn't direct
more prosecutions so here's what session
said in a memo he said quote in deciding
which marijuana activities to prosecute
under these laws with the department's
finite resources prosecutors should
follow the well-established principles
that govern all federal prosecutions
these principles require federal
prosecutors deciding which cases to
prosecute to weigh all relevant
considerations of the crime the
deterrent effect of criminal prosecution
and the cumulative effect
crimes on the community so naturally the
media goes absolutely insane over this
how dare Jeff Sessions he's done
something terrible look at him
now he's just going he's reading the
drug war and that's all that this is
okay that's not really what happened
here as I say the Cole memo was this
directive to federal prosecutors that
basically said that the drug was still
illegal under the federal Controlled
Substances Act but federal prosecutors
could focus their resources elsewhere so
long as the states didn't threaten other
federal priorities such as distribution
of drugs to minors and targeting cartels
that's what the Cole memo did that's now
been overruled the Attorney General
rescinded the Cole memo and marijuana
prosecutions directed that federal
marijuana prosecution decisions be
governed by basic principles of law so a
bunch of people in Congress are alarmed
oh no the DOJ is gonna come after us if
that's the case I have an idea
change the law right here's why sessions
is actually correct so sessions is
correct even if you agree with
decriminalization of marijuana as I do
sessions is not wrong the reason
sessions is not wrong is that we have
something called the executive branch
the executive branch's job is to as you
may have guessed execute it is their job
to execute the law it is not their job
to rewrite the law at will it is not the
job of the federal executive branch to
simply decide as Obama did that we're
not going to prosecute entire classes of
crime because I don't like the law or if
that were the case then I would hope to
get elected president and they just I
would spend zero of the dollars
allocated to me by Congress I just
wouldn't do any of it
I would just nullify everything the
legislature did that's not what the
executive branch is there to do if
Republicans in Congress and Democrats in
Congress have enough of a problem with
pot policy from the DOJ maybe they
should change the law maybe they should
just get rid of the provisions governing
marijuana in the Controlled Substances
Act and let the states deal with it
considering it's mainly a state problem
in the first place I don't know why the
federal government is really involved in
any of this this came to a head and in a
Supreme Court case called California v
Raich in his back in 2003 in which there
was the the federal Controlled
Substances Act came up for a view before
the Supreme Court because the state of
California wanted to allow medicinal
marijuana and the federal government was
coming in to wresting people and people
in California were saying well we
haven't committed a federal crime right
we were not involved in interstate
commerce we're just growing marijuana to
use ourselves right we're growing
marijuana to use it in state
and the Supreme Court wrongly in my
opinion ruled that the state of
California could not do that that it was
a Supremacy Clause question that they
were overruling the federal government I
disagree with that decision I disagree
with the federal government getting
involved in these issues in the first
place but it is not the job of the
executive to nullify federal law it's
the job of the legislature to change
federal law that's basically what sarah
huckabee Sanders said yesterday and I
think that she's basically correct the
president believes in enforcing federal
law that would be his top priority and
that is regardless of what the topic is
whether it's marijuana or whether it's
immigration the president strongly
believes that we should enforce federal
law the move that the Department of
Justice has made which my guess is what
you're referencing simply gives
prosecutors the tools to take on
large-scale distributors and enforce
federal law the president's position
hasn't changed but he does strongly
believe that we have to enforce federal
law okay so his basic idea here is that
the only thing that matters in the end
is that is that the executive branch
does with the executive branch is
designed to do which is to execute the
law so just so there's no question that
this is correct right this is this is
basically correct no matter what you
feel about marijuana so it's time for
Congress to change the law I will say I
think it is hilarious have left has
responded to this and the left doesn't
care about federalism in any other
setting they don't care about states
rights in any other setting they're anti
they're actively anti states rights in
every other setting like against it Cory
Booker however says that this is an
attack on our most sacred ideals like
really this is what he says and so this
is an attack on our most sacred ideals
and the very purpose of the Department
of Justice was just to protect Americans
to elevate ideals of justice and to do
right by people it is a failure of this
administration who said as our president
did during his campaign that he would
honor what states are doing it's a
betrayal of our Attorney General who
gave a commitment to a Republican at
least one looking member of this body
but most significantly it is hurting it
will hurt America you know her America
it's our sacred principle that people
should be able to smoke dope pretty sure
that that was not actually a sacred
principle
like for anyone but apparently for
Democrats babies in the womb not take
red-hot sacred I'm glad that we now know
the priorities this is this is exciting
okay so we are going to get to the
mailbag I also want to discuss this new
FBI investigation into Hillary Clinton
we'll discuss all of that but first
you're gonna have to go over to Daley
wired.com and take a look over there so
for $9.99 a month you get the rest of
the show live you get to be part of the
mailbag subscribe right now you can be
part of the mailbag like right now right
now I'm waiting do it okay we're done
okay so you can do all of that you can
get the rest of Andrew Clavin show live
get the rest of Michael Noel's show live
you get to get all the goodies that we
are going to be giving away at the
Shapiro store which will be happening
also for the annual subscription you get
this the very finest in all beverage
vessels left dis tears hot or cold
tumblr it is so magnificent so grand so
fine that if you are forced to choose
between one of your children and
maintaining the sanctity of this tumbler
it will be a very difficult decision in
the end you will come down on the side
of the tumbler I know I used to have
three children now I only have two in
any case check it out that's not true
guys come on okay so in any case
check out these subscription or go over
to Daley why it's 99 bucks a year by the
way a lot cheaper than the monthly or go
over to SoundCloud iTunes YouTube
subscribe leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest most
most popular fastest-growing most
incredible conservative podcasts in the
nation
yes every week feels like three it's
just that much news and going on in any
case the FBI has now launched a new
investigation into Hillary Clinton the
right of course is celebrating wildly
that this is happening listen I think
that if she did something she should go
to jail I think she should have gone to
jail for what she did in her exposing
classified information in order to
protect herself through her private
server with that said I'm a little
uncomfortable at the precedent that's
being said that we are now going to
spend years prosecuting prior
administrations because if Trump thinks
this is fun now if he loses in 2020
things are going to get extraordinarily
dicey extraordinarily fast like Eric
holds our here's the reality
Trump DOJ isn't doing anything wrong by
investigating Hillary because the holder
DOJ was never going to investigate
Hillary what we now live in a
kleptocracy where the ruling cadre gets
to prosecute the top prosecute its
opposition and protect itself from
prosecution right Eric Holder is
responsible for Hillary Clinton getting
off the hook that's the reality Eric
Holder and Loretta Lynch are responsible
for Hillary Clinton getting off the hook
so Trump going back now and looking at
this again or sessions doing it that
would be in accordance with the rule of
law but just be aware that when
powershift and a will again republicans
will not rule forever there will be some
time in the future near or far at which
democrats take power a lot of people are
going to be put under the gun of the DOJ
again because once you start using the
DOJ as your personal tool to take
revenge against your enemies things
could go wildly wrong in any case the
Justice Department has launched a new
inquiry into whether the Clinton
Foundation engaged in pay to play
politics or illegal activities while
Hillary served as Secretary of State
FBI agents from Little Rock where the
foundation was started have taken the
lead in the investigation they've
interviewed at least one witness in the
last month law enforcement officials
said additional activities are expected
in coming weeks the officials who spoke
only on condition of anonymity said the
probe is examining whether the Clintons
promised or performed any policy favors
in return for largesse to their
charitable efforts or whether donors
made commitments of donations in hopes
of securing government outcomes dissolve
from the hill so one witness has said
that the FBI is is acting an extremely
professional and unquestionably thorough
manner it will be interesting and
fascinating to watch the same left that
has been praising the FBI up the wazoo
because of the Trump Russia
investigation now flip and insist that
it is politically driven so I'm looking
forward to that very much again
we'll have to wait to see what comes out
from all of this my inclination is to
believe that the FBI should have
prosecuted Hillary the first time around
in James Comey botched the investigation
and did so in purposeful manner with all
of that said it is not good that all of
our politics is now caught up in the
hands of the DOJ and the FBI and that's
due largely to criminality but it's also
due to the fact that the DOJ and the FBI
have become politicized tools which is
one of the reasons why Republicans are
kicking back against Robert Mueller
Steve Scalise the the House Majority
Whip he came out yesterday and he said
that the special counsel the the Mueller
is now in question that his legitimacy
is now question is we're now gonna play
politics with every aspect of the
federal government because we don't
trust I think rightly so the DOJ or the
FBI so Steve Scalise will challenge
robert muller and presumably within the
next five minutes the democrats will
challenge the FBI here is your Scalise a
plus you've seen through our oversight
by the way in the house you've seen an
exposure of what I think is a lot of
corruption and real concerns that have
been raised about the special counsel in
fact just the credibility of the special
counsel is very much in question because
as you mentioned so many of the people
that Mueller brought in are the people
working on that we're very anti Trump in
the campaign and still to this day I
mean you can't have people in the
Justice Department working on an
investigation who have a predisposed all
of this is a mess by the way because now
that now the accusation is that Jeff
Sessions over at the DOJ the accusation
is that he was actually trying to lead a
PR campaign undercover against James
Comey even as he's recused himself from
the Russia investigation in the middle
of February and April and March and
April
so just yuck all the way around the DOJ
in the FBI I've been politicized we
don't trust them and so the the lack of
trust in our public institutions
continues to founder until we get into
the business of electing politician it's
really our fault we have to stop
electing politicians who are corrupt and
then using the FBI and the DOJ is to
check on our own stupidity that's not
going to work because the DEA and the
FBI are guess what politicians okay time
for some things I like and then some
things I hate and then the mailbag so
things I like today will only do one
thing I like because we have to get to
the mail back the thing that I like
today is a biography that I'm reading on
Johannes Brahms Brahms of course one of
the great composer
of all time and it's really illuminating
very lengthy bogging for my chance
Wofford and the the book really delves
into who Brahms was a person Brahms
really had an eye toward his toward how
he perceived by future historians he
burned a lot of his papers he didn't
want people delving into his life
Jennifer does a really good job of
checking that out I don't have enough
pronounced Jeon it might be on Swofford
in any case he he does a very good job
of delving into all of the details of
Brahms biography so if you're into
biographies of musicians I am we did
Beethoven a couple of weeks ago this
biography of Brahms is considered the
classic so Jen or Yuans Wofford it's
called Johannes Brahms a biography check
it out okay time for some things that I
hate
okay so we'll begin with this idiotic
suite that has 250,000 likes on Twitter
okay it's a picture of the Doug Jones
who's the Democratic the new democratic
senator from Alabama
and his son who happens to be gay and in
Doug Jones his wife who is swearing in
Doug Jones into the Senate and Mike
Pence is standing there presiding over
it because as the vice president he is
the guy who presides over the Senate
so Doug Jones is standing there and the
gay son looks like he is giving side-eye
to Mike Pence supposedly okay and Tareq
Norman tweets photo of the decade Doug
Jones being sworn in while his openly
gay son quietly disintegrates the soul
of Mike Pence this is so stupid for so
many reasons number one if you think
Mike Pence has never met a gay guy you
are a
okay Mike Pence is the vice president of
the United States is the governor of
Indiana
I'm sure he's worked with gay people I'm
sure he's friends with gay people the
idea that Mike Pence has never met a gay
person is just asinine beyond that this
meme doesn't even make sense look at the
guy's eyes he's not even looking at Mike
Pence he's looking at his mom in this
photo right the angle of the photo makes
it look like Tim big us it is not
ambiguous look at his eyes he is looking
at his mother because his mother is the
one who was swearing and his father at
this point it's just but but again the
people aren't so driven by confirmation
bias that they want to believe that that
Mike Pence is somehow threatened by the
openly gay son yeah right I'm sure
that's the case yeah good good job guys
okay other things that I hate so there's
a website called Mike it is a stupid
website
and Mike cuts a bunch of
videos and ikmi see they cut a bunch of
videos usually about sexuality in the
most sort of abhorrent and the
sensationalistic fashion they cut a
video yesterday about sis men liking
trans women it's a bunch of trans women
meaning men who believe that they are
women and some of whom have had surgery
and makeup done to confirm this they are
complaining that men when they find out
that they actually have penises or our
biological men are unhappy about this
and that means that men must be afraid
of their own masculinity so try to
follow the logic here if you're a man
who doesn't want to have sex with a man
who has made himself up to look like a
woman for the objective world and I'm
not getting into their head maybe you
believe you're a woman doesn't matter
bottom line is does a man have a right
to say I'm not into a penis and like is
that is that okay still apparently not
apparently this makes you gay so if
you're a man who doesn't like a penis
you're gay now I'm very confused by all
of this here's here's the mic video it's
it's not good the idea is that a guy
dating a trans woman makes them gay than
what you're basically saying is that a
trans woman it's not a well okay stop it
there for a second the I'm not saying
that this person is quote-unquote
playing dress-up I don't know what this
person's mental condition is okay I
would suggest this person is suffering
from a delusion and I wouldn't suggest
that that is a fact this person is
suffering from a delusion this person is
not a woman okay this person is not a
biological woman this person may believe
they're a biological woman they may
believe that are very feminine man they
may believe they're a trans woman that's
not the same as a biological woman okay
it's not that a man is the the guy who
is looking at this person and saying
that's a man and I'm not sexually
attracted to that or the guy who
initially takes a look before realizing
that that's a man okay there's nothing
that is wrong with that either morally
or in terms of sensitivity dictating
other people's sexual proclivities I
thought was off the table a guy was
until five minutes ago I would say I
thought it was stay out of my bedroom
now apparently it's get in my bedroom or
you're a sexist right get in here right
and take a look at this yeah no that's
not the way that this works okay you
don't get to dictate to anybody else how
they act this is my problem with a lot
of what's happening in the radical trans
movement is not that these are people
who are just saying leave me alone to
live my life I'm fine with that do
whatever the hell you wanna do you wanna
get a surgery that's your problem you're
an adult you want to go out and have
hormone treatments I don't think it'll
be great for you that's your decision
anyway I'm not your doctor that's your
problem go for it right I'm completely
libertarian on this but it is my problem
when you're suggesting that somehow I am
NOT secure enough in my own masculinity
when I say I'm not into your penis okay
stop this is not logical it doesn't make
any sense it's ridiculous it's it's
actually rather tyrannical and it cuts
counter to the entire privacy movement
that you guys are trying to establish or
you guys to or girls well whatever okay
the whole thing is just silly
and so we can play a little bit more of
this chit but you're ready to pause it
okay am twenty-fourths have been certain
sis men who I find I like the showers
random guys they know they're even in
this shot their approach to trans women
specifically is a very dismissive
approach I think that their view on us
is that of a weak boy they don't really
see us as women so now you're so now
you're a weak boy you understand they're
challenging the masculinity of guys who
don't want to have sex with guys hey
Adam Carolla I had I had a line in in in
I think it is his first book where he
says that we're eventually gonna reach
the point where we challenge the
masculinity of boys who are not secure
enough in their masculinity to be gay I
remember Lee gonna say to young boys
that if you want to show you a real man
and that you're securing your masculine
go over there and kiss another guy
that'll show how secure you are in your
masculinity like that's that's the way
this is going we're pretty much there we
didn't have far to go okay time for the
mailbag let's just go to the mailbag
because I can't do any more than alright
so mailbag time Evan says dear Ben you
say your son is young Tarzan do you
think you will let him do self-defense
like jiu-jitsu or Krav Maga when he gets
older yes I hope he does it's one thing
I wish I'd had growing up because I was
smaller and slighter than the other kids
in class I was also smarter and so this
made for some bullying I wish I had
known how to defend myself better so I
could have beaten some people off that'd
been good I canyon says dear Ben
regarding foreign policy if you had to
pick would you rather see America adhere
to the principles of the monroe doctrine
or the Truman Doctrine if neither of
those completely satisfy you
what would the Shapiro doctrine entail
so for those who don't know the monroe
doctrine basically suggests that the
united states is going to keep the
western hemisphere free of european
influence of the Truman Doctrine says
that we are going to defend democracy
around the world anytime a democratic
regime is threatened by
non-democratic regime we're gonna back
the democracy none of these completely
satisfied me because I don't think that
America's foreign policy interest ended
in South America Latin America in Canada
and the Truman Doctrine which suggests
we have to defend democracy as a chief
priority as opposed to America's liberty
interests I don't think that that's
exact enough I think it's a little too
wilsonian for me so what I would say is
that America's foreign interests lie in
preserving our strength and our morality
and that's a balance because they're
going to be times when we have to
preserve our strength by not being able
to overthrow a regime that will cost us
enormous amounts of time and treasure
and men and blood but we will be
strengthening them we will be
strengthening the world if we stay
strong right it's it's sort of the
principle that if somebody is drowning
you you have to make sure that you are
not going to drown also at the same time
so that you can save other people like
there's the there is a balance here that
I don't think has really taken into
consideration with regard to the
hardline Truman doctor I mean they're
they're not like Hamas was elected by
democracy is that a regime that we now
have to defend I don't think so
Rjay says dear Ben do you think it'd be
a fair trade for Republicans to agree to
amnesty for dreamers in exchange for an
end to chain migration Eve Arif I plus
the abolition of anchor babies well I
mean I think that I'm not in favor of
amnesty for dreamers as a blanket I
think that amnesty for specific people
who are in the country illegally and our
benefit to the United States is the
solution I don't know why I can't
advocate for all of these things if you
ask me would I make that exchange if
that were the choice on the table right
in the end to chain migration Eve Arif I
let's say the wall and abolition of
anchor babies I would probably say yes
because that would now change the system
so dramatically that you'd actually have
a cut-off point but I don't think that
that's what's on the table rachel says
hi Ben I have three degrees but left
academia to start a business with my
husband the last time I went to dinner
with old friends we all men someone
living or dead with whom we'd like to
have dinner I said Winston Churchill
without exception everyone else at the
table said Michelle a Barack Obama these
are smart people well first of all I
quibble how can so many academics be so
stupid where politics are concerned well
the answer is when you spend your entire
life in a bubble you tend to believe
that the only people who are worth
talking to are the people who are sort
of at the upper echelon of the bubble
that's Michelle and Barack presumably
you know the world's greatest and most
beautiful and wonderful people
again I quibble with the idea that I'll
use Denis preggers model here I don't
think that just because you're smart
you're wise and obviously
rains don't necessarily translate to
your knowledge of values to wisdom or to
any sort of historical knowledge 100
says haben my question is how and when
should the welfare state be reformed and
why hasn't the Republican and why
haven't the Republicans initiated any
new legislation regarding this so my
understanding is that that's what
they're trying now is that the next
thing they're gonna try is a welfare
reform that creates new work
requirements for welfare I think that
would be great I think that needs to be
attempted as soon as possible I think
welfare should also be devolved to the
state level in federal welfare should
basically be dismembered Nate says with
your rising notoriety you seemed to have
increasingly become the target of hit
pieces and attacks obviously you don't
have time to respond to them all how do
you choose which ones to take on and how
difficult is it to just ignore the rest
well Nate that's a good question I would
love to respond to all of the attacks on
me and and the stuff that I do and right
I have to determine sort of what the
time investment is I have other things
in my life so it's it's a balance
between how quickly can I respond and
how many people have read the hit piece
am i elevating the hit piece that's full
of falsehoods by even responding to it
or is the thing just so damn long then I
don't have time to pick apart this and
then get into a mano a mano fight with
some idiot who doesn't understand the
points that I'm making and that's also
the question once you respond to
somebody then they respond to you and it
turns into a firefight is that something
worthwhile a Tracy says I watched your
discussion with the Aruban thought it
was great he does say one thing on which
I have a question you stated you didn't
see why the US would get involved in
Syria's you didn't see what the u.s. his
interest was there but you also
described the US as the most moral force
on the planet so we not have a moral
interest in preventing an oppressive
regime like Assad's from committing
genocide and murdering his own people
wouldn't you say that's a moral
obligation thank you for considering my
question I'm a new subscriber in a bit
of a fangirl I appreciate it so here is
my answer my answer is the same as it
was earlier which is if we can do it
without it costing us very much then we
do it if we have to go in there with
boots on the ground and tremendous
expenditures of time and resources we
have to determine how that fosters our
interests and how much it sucks us dry
right so if if that could pressure
button now and the genocide in Syria you
would I would everybody would but if the
question is are we gonna send 20,000
troops in there to take out Assad or a
hundred thousand troops in there to take
out Assad and occupy the country is that
something where America really has an
interest is that is that something that
we can do and this is a serious question
to consider because there are awful
horrible humanitarian crises happening
around the world we have to determine as
a country what the balance of costs and
effects is in each of these
tuitions you know the worst the the the
atrocity the more America has an
interest in stopping it for sure but we
also have to take into account what
exactly the class will be do we get
sucked into another prolonged war in the
Middle East where we really have no
solid interests outside of presumably
stopping Assad who fosters terrorism but
not in the same way as Iran for example
like if you had to change a regime and
spend American resources doing it you'd
have to start with Iran and then move on
to Syria since Syria's a client state of
Iran Morgan's you still prefer do you
prefer still or sparkling water
sparkling that is the answer for anyone
of say in mind
Eimer says are you more conservative
than your father um you know hard to
tell I would say that my dad is more
conservative socially than I am probably
I am more conservative than he is
probably fiscally but I would say that
my dad has he's new I would say that as
I have you know taken a more prominent
position and studied more my dad sort of
gets his reading list from me a lot on
politics so I'll read a book and I'll
pass it on to my dad so his views tend
to mirror mine in a lot of ways but not
in every way Bru says what's the deal
with red states receiving more federal
dollars than blue states receive my
liberal friends say blue states support
the red welfare states how can I respond
well the answer is get rid of federal
welfare and won't be a problem
the reason red states received more
money than blue states on average is
because there are more people in red
state more poor people in red states and
then blue states and they're also more
military bases in red states than blue
states so on a per capita basis more
people are receiving aid in red states
and blue states but it's not the red
states that are voting for the federal
welfare programs you dolt
if you don't want to spend all that much
money on red states I have an idea don't
do it right guess what the red states
agree they're not the ones who are
voting for the additional welfare
programs more in says dear Ben as a
native from Massachusetts and a Fenway
Park security guard I'd love to know
your opinion of David Ortiz in the
Boston Red Sox in general so I was for
most of my childhood a Boston Red Sox
fan secondarily I was a White Sox fan
primarily and then a Boston Red Sox fan
secondarily because I picked up all of
my father's allegiances and he went to
college in Boston with my mom well my
opinion on David Ortiz is that he seems
like a nice guy I am almost certain he
was doing steroids you know it's amazing
to me that he's been able to get away
with with being the one guy who's sort
of allowed to do it and everybody sort
of knew he was doing it again this is
opinion not allegations of fact so you
know I
I went from hitting 20 home runs a year
for the Minnesota Twins to hitting 50
home runs a year for the Red Sox I don't
think that sort of stuff just happens
overnight plus he shared a doctor I
believe with with was it Alex Rodriguez
or poo holes in any case I am a big Red
Sox fan I was I went down to Fenway Park
and stood outside Fenway Park when they
won the World Series in 2004 I like
everybody else in Boston at the time
stayed up all night watching the games
with the Yankees so I'm a Red Sox fan
and and load the Yankees a Jeffrey says
been the Hebrew hammer Shapiro I credit
Andrew Breitbart righteous indignation
is my awakening tax to have tremendous
respect for Andrews career it's a great
book he seemed like he gifted an unique
man I also admire you and your approach
to the issues however my admiration of
both of you has led me to be confused as
to why Android elevates deep down into
Breitbart news when you know Steve to be
such a terrible guy why dad no Breitbart
seemed to like Ben and back when he was
alive all you implore him now was this
an error in judgment by Andrew the
answer is yes and it's also true that
the relationship between Bannon and
Breitbart was wildly exaggerated in the
aftermath of Andrews death I spoke to
Andrew you know before I worked there I
spoke with Andrew Babb and I said who is
this who is this guy because he was
occupying some office space there's some
abandoned office space and that was how
they knew each other was Bannen was
working on a documentary on Andrew
because this is how abandoned
ingratiates himself with powerful people
as he try oh I'll make you famous with
my documentary he did it with Palin you
know Dick Morris he did with Michelle
Bachman he's done with a wide variety of
figures in any case there was a Andrew
was occupying the office space and I
said who's this Bannen guy he said but
bannon's okay he's just kind of I said
are you close to me said no I mean the
answer was no he was not very close with
Steve the exaggerated closeness with
Steve was created as a mythical
aftermath to Andrews death when Larry so
loved was looking for somebody to take
over the company and Steve made a strong
push for it and Larry decided to make
him the the chairman of the company I
don't think that Andrew elevated Steve
at Breitbart news I think Larry elevated
Steve at Breitbart news Steve wasn't
even working at Breitbart news until
Andrew died he literally had no job at
Breitbart news until after Andrews death
so do I think Andrew made an error in
judgment by bringing Stephen to the fold
I do so I think that Andrew would have
elevated Steve to anything remotely
resembling this position no I think
that's I think that's absurd
Thomas says prior to the election you
said you would say that our nation was a
train headed for a cliff Hillier would
greatly increase the speed of the Train
Trump would slightly increase
it would decrease the speed do you still
feel this way and if so what's his
President Trump needed you to turn the
train around well I think that in one
way he has in his decrease to speed
dramatically in one way he is increased
the speed so he has decreased the speed
toward which we are heading toward the
fiscal cliff with his regulatory
policies what's really gonna kill us in
truth is the entitlement programs those
are just going to murder us and the
entitlement programs are not only not
gonna go away under Trump they may grow
under Trump there's an article today in
which Trump was asking why there can't
be Medicaid for all so you know I think
that we're still heading toward the
cliff it's just a lot slower than it
would have been and a lot slower than I
thought it would be in one way we have
elevated the speed of the Train and that
is the the partisan politics and the
hatred in politics has elevated to such
an extent that if Democrats are elected
again in the near future the blowback is
going to be ridiculous right the only
permanent changes that Trump has made
are the courts and the tax cuts
everything else can be reversed by the
Democrats and it will be and not only
will it be they won't go so far to the
left that it will be wild it will be
just insane and that's because of the
partisanship that is that has been
elevated and promulgated and pushed
really really hard Chad says hey man I'm
a longtime fan have you ever lost a
political debate or in your opinion
would you say your opinion was changed
during a debate also I'm calling BS that
you can benchpress 200 pounds Crowder
will back me on this I know I can
actually bench press 300 pounds I can't
do it like a ton of times but I can
bench press 200 pounds it has my opinion
ever been changed during debate not
during a debate I would say but I've
there are many debates where people will
give me facts that I haven't thought
about before and I'll go up and look
them up and see how that changes my
opinion I would say that there are a
couple areas in my career where I've
changed my opinion pretty significantly
I think legalization of marijuana is one
of those and we talked about that today
Christopher says I'm in the military and
with the new policy that will allow
transgenders to serve alongside me I
will be forced to use pronouns in which
I disagree including it functions
outside of work they'll include our
families such as Christmas or holiday
parties like you I don't want my
children to be confused I prefer to
sacrifice myself on behalf of my
children I feel like the sacrifice I
make every day is enough and asking me
to do what comes along with this beyond
what I've conveyed is too much yes I
could avoid these situations but
milestones like me advancing to the next
pay grade I don't want to have to
exclude my children what should I do or
how would you handle this well I mean
I'm sorry that these
are the rules that the military is
pushing I really hope that Madison does
it I hope that Trump undoes it and the
courts that are something to stop this
are acting way outside their brief I
think it's absurd that the government
should have any policy cracking down on
your basic right to say whether someone
is a male or a female it's just crazy
it's just insane
but if that's the policy of the military
then I can't choose for you what to do I
would say that we still need men and
women serving in the Armed Forces and
that you should use all of your power
outside government in order to try and
drive a try and drive a change in policy
that will make you free or Jeffrey says
Durbin do you think Abraham Lincoln was
right to throw away civil liberties like
habeas corpus temporarily during the
Civil War to save the Constitution in
the Union really difficult historical
question I do wonder if Lincoln actually
had suspend habeas corpus in order to
win the Civil War or whether that was an
overkill move by the president during a
time of war that that happens a lot I
mean that's not to blame Lincoln or say
the Lincoln wasn't making a considered
decision in light of the evidence but in
retrospect there are lots of times
during war when we go in virtually every
time during war when he go overboard the
Patriot Act was overextended during the
Iraq war the the internment of the
Japanese during World War Two was
egregious the attempt to prosecute
people under the Espionage Act by
Woodrow Wilson was egregious every time
there's a war there's a tendency to go
overboard in how that war is Perez
prosecuted and I think that suspension
of habeas corpus
difficult for me to believe that was
completely necessary for Abraham Lincoln
to do okay one more question final
question okay final question Nick says
I'm a 26-year old conservative who
happens to be gay I get a lot of crap
for being against gay marriage despite
being gay when asked why I explained why
religion has helped me moved to a good
place morally over the last five years
and how I stand for what I find morally
good and I can say from personal
experience the gay lifestyle has been a
very negative an immoral one for me then
I'm then I get told I'm bigoted because
I hold the religious views in a
political light do you know a better way
to argue this and am I wrong for
thinking this way when when do you as a
person separate your religious beliefs
from politics I don't think I can win it
is a question of morality I don't think
you have to separate your religious
beliefs from politics and I think the
attempt to do so is foolhardy the
reality is we live in a judeo-christian
system that was built on certain values
those values are reflected in our
politics now do you have to make an
argument that is aside from religious
Scripture in order to convince people
yes is that the area where
debate yes because I can't just argue
from the Bible to somebody who doesn't
believe in the Bible it doesn't make any
sense and we're not operating from
operating from a common framework of a
fact I think that you can make a very
solid case for the opinion that you have
based not on the Bible but based on
public policy and the value of marriage
and the value of man-woman relationships
for the upbringing and raising of chair
of children and and serious problems in
a certain aspect of certain types of the
gay lifestyle more promiscuous aspects
of gay lifestyle for example I think you
can make a fine secular argument against
all of those things I would recommend
those are the arguments that you make as
far as the implication that you're a
bigot because you hold certain religious
views I would suggest that anyone who
calls you a bigot because you hold
religious views that don't impact anyone
else though those people are the actual
bigots in the situation okay we have
reached the end of a nearly endless week
but don't worry we'll be back here on
Monday and surely the world will still
be on fire so we will see you then with
the fire hose I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex Zingaro
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess well para the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2017